à 35 ans il sera peut-être bientôt
député européen sur la liste de la
république en marche
jérémy decerle est un homme engagé dans
le syndicalisme agricole depuis ses 16
ans éleveur de charolais il a repris le
flambeau de la ferme familiale au décès
de son père il n'avait alors que 24 ans
aujourd'hui il se lance en politique et
vient de démissionner de la présidence
des jeunes agriculteurs en saône et
loire dans son village cette ascension
fulgurante est accueilli avec fierté
nous sommes très heureux dans le village
de porter notre jeremic et quand même
deux adjoints de notre conseil municipal
et qui représentera bien la campagne
et la raison un village où l'écologie
n'est pas un vain mot
en témoigne ce magasin dont les locaux
appartiennent à la commune et qui
valorisent les produits des agriculteurs
environnants ici jérémy decerle l'enfant
du pays est connu comme celui qui a
gravi tous les échelons
mais surtout comme celui qui sera le
mieux à même de défendre les intérêts
des agriculteurs puis vais aussi tout
simplement pour réaffirmer l'importance
de maintenir des territoires mais jérémy
decerle va devoir composer avec les
engagements pris par la république en
marche sur la fin des pesticides et
notamment du glyphosate employés dans
l'agriculture sur le grip au charme
on a dit pas d'interruption sans
solution donc le travail maintenant
c'est de trouver des solutions donc
d'essayer de répondre à la question
billère les agriculteurs en saône et
loire pour l'instant ne souhaite pas
réagir ils attendent de connaître le
programme de la liste de la république
en marche mais espère en tout cas être
enfin représenté à bruxelles
comme ils ne l'ont jamais été